five
I know I already go 5 4 3 2 1
it was a feeling it's alright do it
again
5 4 - I woke up just now
it's 5 o'clock because it 5 p.m. yep and
it just woke up because uhm what was
gonna I was supposed to be wake up at 1
and I woke up at 1 and then um I was to
go to that APA to do that pitch and I
just couldn't get myself to do it
so I got I woke up just now and the
reason why I woke up though is because
um we have to do this podcast and it's
one of my favorite people
I guess that's guesting but um I swear
to [ __ ] god man it's like you're all
my last nerve
yeah I don't care that your magic spells
and magic bubbles and stuff oh you're
you're a [ __ ] grown adult now I'm
gonna introduce everyone in the room
alright we got George George your
cackling right it's [ __ ] out my last
thing man you yes sir
love it thank you have a lot of
splaining to do you got you my
girlfriend and then we got our guest now
my guest
ok yes I was a TV program television
program government sponsored called
MADtv and when I first got on there was
like this all these older cast members
that came out of order they're like Mike
McKee McDonald and all these people
would be bit older like there are
thousand years okay existence all right
except for her but anything
you know and so will sasso was there it
was super nice to me but this next young
lady you know was so nice to me and you
know it's great yeah she really is she's
a wonderful human being she's seen me do
a lot of weird things you know this is
during when I was uh didn't know who I
was
slept King was just like Prince
lepprince was a [ __ ] baby and the baby
was born why is that reverse order I
have no idea but you know what you know
what Gilbert you know that I go on these
little rants and stuff and you should
just accept it you guys how about a
round of applause for my old friend
who's here mo Collins give her along A+
her namaste young gay Oh God now when
did I see you last uh last I said last
when last I saw Bobby we did dream core
we dream coordinated ease
I was I had my face in your Ted yeah
yeah yeah but and seen you before that
for many long time many years yeah yeah
like why well I think we're both ones to
isolate yeah we getting right to it yeah
we're gonna isolate you and I would
venture to say that you probably do that
more than me you think that I isolate
more than you I do that's interesting I
do think that that's not a I'm not
accepting it couple texts I sent you
that I never got a return oh well that
now you know that that's being that's me
being me
you know man I say back to you in text
as well I was reaching out from my couch
yeah yeah yeah and mo
when I got on MADtv you were there today
we would say aye
I did two seasons with you you're asking
me how many seasons ya know what I did
with you specifically oh I came on
halfway during a season I think you did
another year after that I I went through
a middle of two middle of Wow
season four maybe five six seven eight
middle of nine I left middle of nine
that was it and I started in seven
okay the seventh so I did a couple years
with you so yeah that was fun those are
great years yes they were and I relapse
I was 12 years sober I relapsed and I
we're in Vegas and what did I do in
Vegas do you really want me to see yeah
go ahead
well we go to Vegas yeah but I think
Barinholtz was there for sure there was
a bunch retailer Rico was there yeah the
gang it was fun
oh my gosh what would I do what did you
do yeah yeah which which moment in the
Bellagio in the Bellagio in the hotel
room
whoever okay that's what I didn't take
let's take the folks to the hotel yeah
yeah okay room packed with our crew yeah
must have been I don't know at least 10
people maybe more yeah
Bobby had brought along yes Pacific you
remember unpaid her to do so yeah yeah
okay lovely gal what I remember is I
myself was sitting at one point now this
it was a crazy time yeah I'm sitting up
on the bed and oh yeah wow it really
comes back to the brain the visual Bob
Bobby comes out of the bathroom fully
naked like trying to pull off a hat
trick like he's rubbing his belly with
one hand
on the other hand was jerkin his way my
room
my rules like where people do very hard
to do well that was the first time I had
ever done ecstasy its I was drinking and
then ecstasy and it really like if even
when you when you're in your thirties
and you hear about this drug okay it's
just when you're sober in your thirties
and people go and then when you relapse
and you finally do it it just kind of
hit me in a weird way do you do you
remember hello do you remember even
before this moment flying to Vegas I
think it was that yeah yeah what was we
sat next to each other on the plane yeah
before takeoff you pull out a baggie
yeah thank God it was a baggie yeah yeah
loaded with pills yeah like I had never
it was it looked like you know
children's toys it was a bag of adult
candy uh-huh and I panicked because you
know I'm a good Irish Catholic girl from
India wild I've had some your [ __ ]
I've had some moments
it's not even moment just let's just get
this a real out there okay done
something all right so go ahead but I I
panicked cuz I'm just thinking the
steward this is gonna come along I don't
know yeah I don't know what happens in
did you see some no you never ate on my
pills no I didn't know I definitely
didn't know some people I didn't know I
didn't know what you had that people
know but I panned and then they started
slightly not over do you know what I
mean like he's like like Bobby no no I
took this Vegas trip you know to it
partly to like get away from being a
mother
yeah
little child back at home and Here I am
Bobby now what's your pills away Bobby
yeah yeah you know that was intense
I'll tell you another story that MO then
she's gonna bring up these things okay
there's like a TCA party for you know at
the Mondrian with at the Mondrian how
dare you you did it yeah you know it's
just like you know at a tea party right
you now you're you have everyone's in
ballroom gowns and you know the
executives are there and people just
have this woman she's in a ballroom gown
she's in the pool no one's in the pool
oh no that's not true well who was
awesome the mermaids were in the pool
the actor yeah you know how it parties
they'll hire oh there are mermaids which
is that's why I went in be a mermaid
yeah yeah it was the big Fox party and I
just heels and always II that night down
into the pool swimming floatin and I
yeah then I threw up in the limo on the
way how did you really going up and over
Laurel yeah yeah I did and then the next
day or the Monday whatever I got called
into the office cuz they had to do
damage control yeah on me oh really yeah
good you were wild that night thing to
do when you're speaking yeah here's
another thing I know about yeah not the
best idea here's one here's why you do
so like part of you thinks and at least
in that crazy brain is like well I'm on
the sketch comedy show I'm supposed to
be crazy we can get away with this stuff
Yeah right
[Music]